good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast I am so excited it is hump day
which is kind of like an amazing day
here at the toast and I feel like it's
extremely appropriate that I'm joined by
Cody Rigsby on this very special hump
day we we love to hump on hump day we do
I hope everyone out there gets to hump a
little bit today yeah someone they love
yeah yeah I am so excited to talk to you
I know you've been making the rounds yes
your book has come out yes XOXO Cody and
I'm halfway through it it's amazing
thank you so much and of course like you
have this fabulous life I think everyone
knows you from Peloton you were on
Dancing With the Stars and you're kind
of just like
like a celebrity Now isn't it so crazy
it is a little bit crazy so when people
say it I'm like but you are yeah no I'm
I'm fully embracing it you're a star
you're on Dancing With the Stars you
know but some of the stars on that show
are questionable you know they
definitely you know play fast and loose
with the words yes yes yes yes yes yes
you know not you we're pivoting the way
we Define star yeah yes I find so much
about you so interesting and I have to
give credit where credit is due Jackie
has really been obsessed with you she is
a Peloton girl yes yes I've heard I live
in a small apartment so like I just
don't have that luxury but she lives in
a house okay well there's the app you
know you could you can you know there's
body weight classes you know I love a
Shameless plug you know we're always
going to find a way to Pivot you got me
there okay
um so she has loved you and honestly I
was late to the game and I'm obsessed
your book is so good I'm only halfway
through it but there's so many
interesting stories and I feel like of
course you live this fabulous life like
we just said you're a celebrity but you
had this kind of crazy life up until
that point just filled with I can't
believe you worked at the box I did I
did I'm gonna say I'm glad that you
enjoyed my book because I heard that you
think that men can't write books I do
let me say two things so I hope I hope
to be the exception to that rule okay I
know I got you girl okay let me say two
things uh-huh I was really talking about
fiction okay okay like they're not good
storytellers that's fair and like let's
be real I was talking about straight men
like Fair double Fair like you're
writing stuff forget forgiven yeah your
writing style is so funny and quick and
it's like the exact type of book I want
to read and I love celebrity Memoirs
it's one of my favorite genres and I
totally give yours my stamp of
approvement good good excellent and I
really feel like you've learned so much
about you and for me like when I look at
your life I see so many interesting
things like of course I don't I can't
even remember like a Sim someone to
compare you to who really got so famous
off of exercise like yeah and maybe like
a Richard Simmons and I talk about it
later in the book yes like a Richard
Simmons he really created this platform
where he was silly he didn't take
himself so seriously he was fun he
brought levity to this like kind of
scary space I think when people think of
Fitness or starting a fitness journey
they're like I don't know what I'm doing
I'm gonna look stupid and Richard was
like okay ladies get back we're gonna
pump it to the oldies and I'm gonna look
a fool for you so I do kind of pay
homage to him in the book and give him
credit where credit's due it's giving
Richard Simmons it's also giving Lisa
Rinna and her taste
[Laughter]
no it's so interesting and I just I've
Loved reading about and about your
journey but what's so interesting about
it too is I feel like
you get on every day and there's seven
million homes right and you talk
you talk and talk and talk and talk and
talk and I have so many thoughts on that
because you know the couple a handful of
times I've worked out in my life like I
am not okay I have to literally go to
the hospital for two hours afterwards
seriously like how are you doing it all
in terms of like physical fitness and
and were you in this kind of shape
before you did your Peloton training
okay so as a kid growing up I wasn't
very athletic I've said it before like I
was the tetherball champion of Guilford
Middle School so that was like the
extent of my physical abilities
um I became a dancer so that is
obviously very physical
um and you have to hold a lot of stamina
doing that but I never taught a fitness
class before so like talking teaching a
class knowing the programming was all
foreign to me
um so it took me a lot of time to figure
out how to build that stamina but also I
was a very eccentric child so I've
always been someone that just talks and
talks and talks and talks so it wasn't
until I realized that like I could be
myself and do this little Fitness gig
and like Infuse the two together that I
was really able to like find who I was
yeah and like kind of
do it in a really singular way that I
don't see really anything yeah you know
yeah and I really love that's what I was
shocked to find out in your book is that
like you didn't have this crazy Fitness
background Peloton really trained you
they saw something in you and I think
that's so cool and not what I would have
expected I would have expected you were
Like Making Waves in the fitness scene
which I wouldn't have heard about yeah
yeah no but like that's the thing is I
I've been in the company for nine years
so back then it was just a startup and
they were just like trying to find
talent and they're like you're cute
you'll do you know so they were willing
to take a chance on someone who didn't
know what they're doing and I also was
like okay I've got to just figure it out
yeah and I figured it out that was part
of your book that really resonated with
me that's when I knew I liked the book
it was literally on like page four when
you were just like I'm not gonna you
know be shy I knew when I was a young
kid like I knew I was a star yeah and
not to make everything about me like I
related to that on a deep level like I
really and I think it's okay to say that
I absolutely I'm special because no one
if you don't say it other people are not
going no one else will yes it's so true
you gotta you gotta know that you're a
star baby so you talk while you're
working out which to me is just
unbelievable and you have this
unbelievable personality and immediately
connected with people and you do and you
became known for like a lot of your pop
culture tastes yes now you and I differ
okay on certain things and we'll get
into that I love I love a healthy debate
especially about pop stars on pop
culture yes I think it like it just
keeps friendships you know going and
it's not that deep it's not that deep it
can get a little nasty but it All is
Forgiven but you know I know that you
and I will meet in the middle when it
comes to Kelly Clarkson okay all right
all right for that I think we're we're
safe everybody loves Kelly the the
original American Idol literally
America's sweetheart and I this is my
hot take on that it's like our country
was the most United when we elected
Kelly Clarkson as an American Idol I was
calling we were we picked up the phone
on Singular Wireless right we dialed up
the number and we called 10 times I was
an Optimum girl okay Optimum yay
but you grew up in the Northeast yes
okay that's why I was in the South oh
right yeah but we were doing the work we
were doing the work and I feel good
about what we did but I do feel like as
a nation we have sort of like like Kelly
Clarkson down I don't feel like she gets
nearly the amount of hype that she
really deserves as a vocalist as Talent
wow like she she should she and she's
huge she should be bigger I think the
gays do I agree they get yes the gays
will give Kelly her her flowers and then
some it's true she's also just made this
like great pivot where she's like a talk
show host she's on the she's on The
Voice like she is really keeping the NBC
Network like she's holding it on her
back I know no wonder she's like always
tired like she's literally has the whole
world on her shoulders yeah and I got to
be on her show tell me everything she
was amazing it was very quick it was
like I arrived
behind her pic she like has a massive
pickup truck in the lot so like I got
dropped off in front of course they like
whisked me to The Green Room 10 minutes
like they're like you're on and like wow
the doors open and I'm meeting Kelly
Clarkson and she's asking me about my
life and I'm sure she was a doll but oh
amazing incredible but just quick yeah
she has no show going she's a mother
she's a singer she's a businesswoman
she's a mobile she doesn't have time she
doesn't have time and so you have gotten
you know so popular and people really
tune in because they love your classes
but they really want to hear what you
have to say yeah on what's going on in
the world and I know you've experienced
you know some of your hot takes not
being received so well and I'm gonna ask
you a question and then I'm also gonna
ask you to move your mic a little close
to your mouth okay I'm gonna pull it
yeah there we go how does that make you
feel like does that give you anxiety
like when you say something in people
like it's because it does for me this is
fair like I
um
I think it comes back to yeah I'll say
yes so most of the time like my hot
chicks I'm just like throwing them out
there and I don't care and I'm just like
you know what like let's have fun yeah I
think in the era that we're in
um sometimes really people take things
to heart and they're not understanding
the tone that you're saying the sarcasm
right the levity the fun like we're just
trying to have fun and people take it
very seriously and then tend to like
throw some nastiness at you
um and for the most part I can take it
I'm fine but yeah I think once it starts
to compile it kind of gives you it gets
you and you have to do normal yeah I
need like let this pass and like we'll
keep pumping but yeah and I feel like
for you like at the end of the day your
goal is just to like get everyone
through their workouts right yeah and be
be silly be fun and it's like it would
be the same conversation like we just
talked about if we're debating something
or being stupid with friends
it's not going to have any weight it's
not that deep boo yeah yeah so I agree
with so I'm really excited to get your
takes on a lot of the stories by the way
I was cackling when you dedicated your
book to Britney Spears yes the one and
only so funny we have a Britney story
today I was going to talk about it
anyway but I would love to hear it yeah
because it's an interesting time to be
to be a BJs stand what you said you
better use the middle name would you say
um
yeah it's it's getting really
challenging
for us to like stand for our girl and
also be very adamant about the like
still hashtag free Brittany right
because she's free where were you during
the free Brittany movement I was letting
the girls know that like she was under
conservatorship like it's been way too
long people are taking her money
relatives are not treating her well
certain Dancing with the Stars
contestants named to be named yes is
that your season no no she's on it right
now oh you're right oh my God yes we
also have a dancing with the star story
we'll get to that um so it's getting
hard but here's my take is that like
and I hate to use the word like crazy so
I'm not going to use it just like
everyone has the right to be as unhinged
as they possibly want yes
um and as long as like you're not
hurting yourself or others then like be
as unhinged as you want everyone has the
right to be a mess
um
so let Britney be a mess I will also say
this and this is kind of on a more
serious note like I take care of my mom
and there was a point where I moved from
North Carolina to Brooklyn Brooklyn and
her doctor was prescribing her lithium
oh my God yeah and like she became
lithium toxic and it really had kind of
irreversible effects on her and I've
been able to like things are better but
there's definitely like you know things
that are irreversible within my mom that
I've witnessed and so you know the
stories are is that they were
prescribing Britney like lithium and so
part of me in a way feels like
where she's at right now isn't
necessarily her fault no of course not
and we need to have a little bit more
grace and understanding and compassion
that being said like I would love to see
her stop like shopping at stripper store
like I feel like she gets all her attire
that she wears from like the mall the
the mall like sex store and like she got
the stripper pole yeah like not even and
like honey I don't the knives concerned
me we have a story about the knives the
knives concerned me that actually I
think like was a uh and she actually
gives an explanation and we'll talk
about it but to me like I see her videos
I'm like you know what it's not what I
would do no but she's enjoying her life
yes the knives I think we're concerning
we were and I I do want I like I guess
not that I'm worried about the kids but
like I know if that was my mom I'd be
like well you talk a lot about your
family in the book and what's so
interesting to me is like I think the
first word most people would use to
describe you is like out there
and you've dealt with so much and I
think a lot of people probably really I
lost my dad too so hearing about you
experiencing that was really
um relatable and I think I think a lot
of people would wonder how you maintain
that level of outgoing like we were just
saying effervescent when you've dealt
with what you've dealt with
um I think for me like life has been
hard like I've dealt with homelessness
my my father died when I was young my
mom had addiction issues so life was
heavy but like I embraced that and
forgave a lot of that like I forgave my
mom for her mistakes also came to kind
of understand and you might not relate
to this like my dad also died of an
overdose and I kind of
growing up like was resentful or sad
that I didn't have a dad but as I grew
up I was like it was probably for the
better that this person wasn't in my
life it would have made it so much more
chaotic right and how can I really have
an attachment to someone that I didn't
necessarily know so I've kind of like
processed that yeah let it go and really
just tried to find the joy in life I
think also as a kid growing up with a
lot of trauma I used like comedy and fun
of course to kind of cope yeah and get
through and that's been like a defense
mechanism but I think I've also embraced
that and just known that that's who I am
yeah I think people and you know through
no fault of their own it swallows them
up like especially and you can either
choose to laugh at life and move past it
but sometimes it's hard I think people
really look at you and find it very
inspiring thank you I really do
appreciate it I always say like yes life
is hard but like laugh at it so you can
laugh at yourself and it you don't give
shame or guilt power you like you
embrace your own power yeah so now that
you're an author uh-huh do you have
because this happened to me like I had
this kind of like I don't want to use
word like like I thought it was better
than everyone like I'm an author are you
experiencing that
[Music]
um
I don't think I'm better than anybody I
think I've I've elevated and evolved and
I think it's a new thing for me era sure
yes
um I mean I was really excited about
being a New York Times best-selling
author sir yes thank you yes that that
really popped off for me and made like
all the hard work feel really good and
that's something nobody can take away
from you exactly like that's so legit my
colleague tunde was like it's like
getting a doctorate degree like they
can't take that thing and anytime you do
anything like if you're gonna speak on a
panel or yeah they're gonna say that
they're gonna say Fitness enthusiasts
New York Times best-selling author
opinionated homosexuals Cody Rigsby it's
just it's so simple now can we just get
it on my AmEx like can it just you know
how they have doctor on the Amber I
might know a guy okay thank you you know
Brian Kelly yeah
so you're gonna join me for all the hot
stories of the day and then we're gonna
do you're very well known for giving
advice your book is called XOXO code you
actually give advice in the book and you
do a segment on Pelton which I love
called XOXO Cody where your writer
writers will write in yeah so you're
gonna help me out with that and we have
a lot of stories and I just want to
issue you know a bit of a trigger
warning our first story is about Taylor
Swift okay here we go and one of the
things I think a lot of people know
about you is you made waves just kind of
you know giving your thoughts they
weren't overwhelmingly positive no no
it's just not my girl okay give just
kind of set the scene for everyone who
might not be familiar with your stance
oh wow I just like Taylor's not my girl
I don't really react to her music I
don't really react to like
things that she does in pop culture
she's just not for me have you tried I
have okay I have so I had a boyfriend in
college Who Loved Taylor Swift and for
the record like I really did enjoy like
the country era like Teardrops On My
Guitar Tim McGraw I really loved that I
really did I I love those two songs and
I will admit here like I love Tim McGraw
uh Teardrops On My Guitar and for the
1989 girlies like I I will I will say
this like bad blood does slap 100 it
slaps I do love that song I hate to
admit it and that's about the extent of
my love for Taylor's music
um I will try and you seem like a smart
person like I can't change your mind I'm
like that too like I feel the same way
about AC DC and Led Zeppelin like it's
not for me you know what I'm saying all
right you taking it a little okay okay
there we go no but like okay so I'm not
gonna try and convince you of anything I
just I find it so surprising because you
clearly like love and ride for so many
pop girly yes so who would you say
number one Brittany Brittany is my
number one but you know like she's not
putting anything out so like a lot of
it's nostalgic yes but I think Beyonce
at this point is like my number one like
she's putting out relevant music the
last album was really for the girls gays
and days the Renaissance tour was the
best thing I've ever seen she's still
giving 110 percent
um like there's just nobody else out
there like her I'm gonna rattle off some
of the pop girlies and you give me like
your immediate thought okay so we did
Beyonce okay
Kim Petras Kim Petras
um uh Trailblazer
um I love that I think that's the sound
that I want to hear from pop music but
the world doesn't want to hear that the
world doesn't like pop music by the way
that's an amazing take like they're she
makes great music but the world doesn't
want that she makes the best music like
so fun she's her vocals are so good yes
that's an amazing call yeah Okay Lady
Gaga Lady Gaga
um
oh
um like she my thing is like she really
changed the pop stars Fashions yeah
before Lady Gaga everybody was wearing
like a dress over a jean and then Lady
Gaga popped off and everyone was in a
body including Beyonce yeah like go back
no I love it like Beyonce was wearing
some choices that Tina Knowles made for
her and then Lady Gaga said I'm gonna
get the girls together and everyone was
in like
a shoulder pad a bodysuit a platform a
bob bang like it was giving you know
what I'm saying it's an amazing call
yeah like Katy Perry Katy Perry uh the
the queen of corny I think she makes the
most amazing these are amazing tape
corny songs that like everybody loves to
sing and they just make you feel girly
and fun
yeah Ari Ariana
um
[Music]
messy not messy like such a great
musician one of the better vocalists of
our time agreed like no one's singing
like her right now like
you know what I'm saying like nobody can
sing like her
um
the choices in men is unique it's Unique
I want to know I want to like unpack
that yeah it's definitely bizarre it
definitely I think is indicative of
growing up
um a child star yeah like in musical
theater okay yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes but they're not
that I would make
in Hollywood
yeah it's like she's at theater camp and
she's only she's finding the one
heterosexual exactly no exactly like
right yeah and that one heterosexual has
definitely gotten their dick sucked Yeah
by a man because he's a victim of
circumstance yeah yeah he was there he
want to try and there's nothing wrong
with that I'm glad he tried he tried and
he knew he didn't like it yeah you know
and I respect him for that have you ever
guest judged on drag race no it's my
dream job and they will not call me
really we gotta make that happen obvious
choice I know we're gonna make it we're
gonna manifest it let's manifest it I
would love to see you on there thank you
what are your who's your number one drag
queen one from the show contestants wise
oh that's a hard one but who I really
respect is like Shangela Bob the drag
queen I love Eureka uh Trixie I love
Eureka Eureka's Eureka is probably one
of my favorites just because she was so
herself yeah kind of annoying like me
yeah and it could be a lot for some
people it could be a lot
erased it and what I also like is from
her season well she was on one season
she kind of she heard she hurt herself
oh she's a fan okay oh yeah no she and I
was very upset because I do feel like I
love drag race but I feel like the plus
size queens get no love no love it's
hard for the big girls I know um but
from her first season to her comeback
season I feel like she really did some
work yeah and changed as a person and
was like Hey I'm being annoying and
abrasive and I'm gonna like I'm gonna
work on myself a little bit can I ask
you a question yeah yeah because I feel
like we have similar personalities and
big personalities yeah very big and I
think sometimes people with big
personalities like are I'm self-aware
enough to know like I'm not for everyone
and sometimes I could be annoying is
that something you deal with like
self-consciously like are my too much
and should I pull back
no no no I I think I've always just
known I'm like I'm I'm a lot I think
when I was a kid of course I want to be
like by everybody right but I think I
was like I'm a lot I'm loud I'm
opinionated and once I accepted that I
really found my voice especially like
within the public eye and at Peloton and
people embrace it and they love that and
like you're not going to be everywhere
as cup of tea so true and that's okay
that's okay yeah okay Cody Briggs we
have a question for you are you ready
for the past five stories let's go
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by saks.com we are always doing
our best when it comes to looking
fabulous on this here podcast sometimes
our pajama uniforms and our sweatshirts
sad need a little bit of an upgrade
though and that's why we love shopping
at saks.com for everything from podcast
Luke's gno outfits you know I'm saying
yes to life this year and that requires
quite a bit of a wardrobe and saks.com
has me covered from head to toe it is
super fun and easy to shop on saks.com
whether you're going for a cozy Vibe
which more often than not I am or if
you're looking for a more elevated look
they have got it all at sax.com at
sax.com it's also so easy to shop
there's so many different ways to filter
through the results you can shop by your
star sign or even by your situation like
if you're going on vacation you need
looks they make it really easy to filter
for exactly what you're looking for it's
like finding the perfect Revenge dress
from Brands like Christopher esber cult
Gaia they have I feel like sax is so
good at Discovery like the best new hot
brand and that you can buy and then like
next year everyone's gonna have it and
you're gonna be cooler than everyone
because you shop at sex.com so you can
discover new ways to shop for everything
everyday attacks.com as a new yorker's
tax is like a institution and I love
shopping there I think they're um
customer service and their delivery are
fabulous easy returns I love shopping at
stocks.com can't recommend them enough
and that's how I stay looking so stylish
not gonna lie because I'm stunting on
everyone thanks to sax.com today's
episode is also brought to you by
neutralfall so as you guys know I have
experienced hair shedding in the last
year and did you know that hair thinning
will happen to approximately one in two
women if you're among them no you're not
alone there's nothing to be embarrassed
about it's so normal and neutralfall
helps women address it from within with
science-backed supplements so neutral
what is it it is a number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement it's clinically shown to
improve visible thickness and strength
and I can attest to that 100 I started
my hair growth Journey at the beginning
of the year and when I reached out to
like people on Instagram or just like my
close family and friends everyone
recommended neutral foam from postpartum
to menopause to plant-based lifestyle
whatever your life stages nutrifall has
four unique formulas to support women
each is physician formulated and it uses
drug free science-backed ingredients so
you get the most reliable results you go
to nutrivall.com take their hair Health
Wellness quiz and then you can identify
causes of your thinning and nutrifall
will give you a personalized plan for
better hair growth through their whole
body approach so there's a million
different reasons why you might be
experiencing it it's totally normal like
I said menopause postpartum I experience
sit because I had like a complete shift
in diet and that is really natural to
cause hair thinning and hair shedding in
the clinical study 86 percent of women
reported improved hair growth after
taking neutrophone women's hair growth
supplement for six months take the first
step to physically visibly thicker
healthier hair for limited time
nutrifall is offering our listeners ten
dollars off their first month
subscription and free shipping when you
go to nutrifall.com and enter promo code
the toast find out why over 4 000
Healthcare professionals recommend
neutrofall for healthier hair
nutrifall.com and that's spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code the toast
that's nutrifall.com promo code the
toast today's episode is brought to you
by Lululemon because we are celebrating
the fact that legging season is upon us
we don't have to wear shorts and shave
effects anymore it's lagging season it's
comfy sweater season and Lululemon is
the place to shop if you need leggings I
love all of my Lululemon leggings I
think they make the best leggings I
really I'm very particular about
leggings I don't like to be constricted
I don't like to not be able to breathe
and Lulu women has it all this season so
they have a ton of different leggings
the fast and free leggings which are
powered by their new Luxe fabric they're
really weightless they have incredible
coverage and they're designed for those
looking for a legging that gives them
complete freedom from distractions while
running or jogging they also have the
Wonder train legging which is designed
with one of their most Innovative
Fabrics which is everlux it is their
fastest drying fabric so that legging
allows you to work hard and feel dry so
you can effortly transition from sweat
to Street if you're working out but you
also want to run errands like you're not
going to be in your soggy clothes all
day and you can actually get sick that
way so don't do that it's great for any
activities and then the Align leggings
which are personally my favorite ones
they're powered by the nulu fabric so
it's really for the person who wants a
lightweight low compression yoga
solution that is also versatile enough
for casual wear because stay with me you
don't have to work out to wear workout
clothing it gives the wearer a next to
nothing body sensation it has full
freedom of movement and it doesn't
restrict or compress whoever's wearing
it it's great for low intensity workouts
like yoga or just casual wear pair it
with a sweater maybe a pair of boots you
know it's Autumn girl it's girl fall
girl Autumn what are they calling it
Christian girl Autumn whatever get into
the Lululemon leggings at lululemon.com
that's
l-u-l-u-l-e-m-o-n.com okay so our first
story is about Taylor okay now I'm gonna
give everyone the update but what are
your thoughts on her dating Travis
Kelsey this you know okay Monumental
moment yeah he's hot first of all first
of all very hot love the mustache he's a
little bit like uh you know
goofy corn fed trashy I'm here I love a
corn a corn fad I agree um so he's hot
um also like she definitely needs
someone tall she's a tall gal It's hard
out there for tall girls especially if
you're wearing heels these men are very
intimidated by a tall girl so like she
needs a tall man he's tall
um she also needs someone that is
successful she's one of if not the most
successful woman in music and in the
world right now so she needs someone
successful but like adjacent or not or
like on a different Lane they're not
sharing the same space like he's not a
musician he's not gonna get intimidated
like he's at the game he's throwing the
ball or catching the ball I'm not
catching the ball he's the bottom great
wonderful okay
um so he's out there catching ball the
ball and you know he looks great in red
and so I think it's good and but like
I'm I'm really interested to see like I
saw like his jerseys like number five
like 87. oh number 87 no no I'm saying
like of purchases on the NFL website
like 400 yeah it's 400 so the girls the
swifties are buying their jerseys I just
like can't wait to see like when they
break up like he's going to they are
going to let him have it he's gonna
literally never want to leave his house
again the girls say that Taylor doesn't
write songs about X's anymore I I can't
like say yay or nay for that by the way
she does I think with the swifties have
a problem with if I could be a
representative is when people minimize
Tailors and all of her success being
like oh she just writes songs about her
ex-boyfriend no I I won't say that I
won't say that but she does write a lot
about her accent yes yes and that
encompasses men yes they attack our
lives and you know I think it's worth
mentioning that pretty much everyone
writes about love every song ever is
written about love but when Taylor does
it it's like an issue okay yep fair fair
fair take
um I just am gonna really look forward
to that man that I pray for that boy
when in a year there are football and
allergies in one of her songs and they
are like leaving snakes all over his
Instagram yeah so brace this man for
impact keep him in your prayers right
now what the swifties giveth this is the
whole they will take it away yes he got
400 000 Instagram followers yes his
jerseys went up in sales by 400 yes
there were 25 million people watching
that game what the swifties giveth the
swifties will take but okay here's also
here's like because I love Pop cultures
I guess
let's like manifest though like
him a
a year and so from here so Super Bowl
2025. okay Taylor's performing and he's
in the game oh what are you that's on
what are your thoughts on Usher Usher
being the Super Bowl one of the only men
that I would allow to be the Super Bowl
like headliner because a take that I
have is like get men off that stage oh
my God you are making the best calls
today get men off that stage immediately
agree like why are they on that stage
doing nothing except I don't think that
applies to Bruno Mars oh my God we are
so in alignment that is the one that he
his Super Bowl performance I was not a
fan I was like okay whatever I watched
that and I was like oh this boy's
turning it yeah he was incredible no I
have gone back and watched it's like one
of my favorite activities on a Saturday
when I'm drunk I'm like guys let's let's
watch Bruno Mars what if we just watch
Bruno Mars at the Super Bowl okay I
agree with you Usher is I think and he
has a catalog he's my favorite male
artist of all time really yeah because
he's a [__] but he also like loves being
in love okay and I relate to that
like I'm I'm assuming I don't make
assumptions like I'm assuming you're
familiar with Mr J yes yes she's a [__]
and Chin yes yes yes yes that show would
uh not no go these days when I was in it
was wildly inappropriate it was beyond
inappropriate when I was in college I
was an intern at The Huffington Post
okay and they had a Halloween party okay
great so I was in my Jimmy Obsession and
I dressed up as Jimmy privates when I
tell you not one person knew I was I
looked so [__] stupid but it was the
best costume of all time I wasn't
appreciated in my own time you should
have been what's the best Halloween
costume you've ever done oh wow best
Halloween costume that I've ever done do
you do a lot of Pop Culture no I'm
actually like kind of a more nerdy girl
like I did like video games and like
Marvel growing up last year I was Rogue
and my ass looked really good rogue
rogue from the X-Men so yeah
wow you really have so many interests I
know me and my friend we me and my best
friend we we dressed up as Cami and Chun
from Street Fighter and it was really
great because like I was like I know
it's fine but it's so important to have
hobbies anything I do I just have to be
a [__] because that's the rule I love
that yep
um okay so the update from the Travis
Kelsey thing I don't know Travis and his
brother have a podcast oh wonderful it
launched last year when they became
really popular because they were both
playing in the Super Bowl and it was the
first time two brothers had ever been oh
that was them yes oh wow I had no idea
so they launched a podcast and people
they're just America has fallen in love
with them and they're hot they're hot
they're hot and they're so different
like Jason is a family man he has three
kids he lives in Pennsylvania he's been
on the same team for a million years
he's kind of like the steady one okay
and Travis is more of like the he's a
little bit more of the starry flashy one
um he won the Super Bowl against his
brother oh right yeah he has a ring and
he probably Rings it up everything for
sure oh two I'm so sorry okay so on
their podcast this week it came out this
morning he's talking about Taylor so
they really turned that around quickly
because she was at the game on Sunday or
Sunday yeah and it's not gonna last it
might not last forever the number one
podcast in the world they talked about
it for 35 seconds and it's literally
number one on you it's number one
everywhere but here's basically what he
said
I want to respect both of our Lives
she's not in the media as much as I am
doing this show every single week and
having uh fun during the NFL season but
I'm enjoying life and I sure as hell
enjoyed this weekend everything's moving
forward I think me talking about sports
will just have to be where I keep it so
he's basically saying like yes this is
real but I'm not going to be talking
about it I don't think that's through a
choice of his own he has a great
publicist yeah I mean I can't remember a
time where some are you it was published
yeah yeah
we'll talk later
no I can't remember a time where an
athlete has become so famous so quickly
yeah yeah he's always people know him in
the Sports World he's always been a very
good player and I was gonna say is he
like is he good because he's but he's
got two rings he's like the best at what
he does oh and that is
I'm gonna say tight end correct tight
end um the football I'm not like other
girls are so gay but okay great totally
yeah yeah um he's a tight end and my
most favorite thing about him which I
think he would really find interesting
is that I want to say in like 2011 I
can't remember right here he was
obviously like experiencing a lull in
his career I think he's actually said
recently that he did it because he was
uh in a fight in financial straights and
he had blown through his rookie money he
did a dating show on Eve called catching
Kelsey what website what website was he
on okay he did a dating show called
catching Kelsey catching Kelsey what
what network was it on it was actually
Eve I recently went back and watched it
it was hysterical and the girl who won
they ended up dating for four or five
months okay she's now speaking out and
she said it was the like funniest thing
she goes I'm a girls girl so I want to
tell Taylor like one's a cheater always
a cheater oh gosh I don't know if a
girl's girl would go to the Daily Mail I
think a girl's girl would go to Taylor
had that been the church
Swift but you know it's okay such a good
point it was just very hypocritical like
you know it's also 2011. it was a long
time 12 years ago like let a man change
yeah that's a little rude oh yeah in
your book you talked about how you
cheated on an um damn read drag me [__]
sorry no but I thought that was very
honest of you yeah yeah I know I
definitely I cheated a lot of boyfriends
but I was also like young and dumb and
like I didn't go and then I finally went
to therapy and was like hey [__] like
that's why stop yeah stop being a
dumbass yeah that was interesting so I I
don't think that like a person from 12
years ago like has had some has had some
time to change and also like they've
gone on a few dates he can [__] other
people right now it's so true you can
[__] other people right now they're not
exclusive they were even holding hands
in that like they were standing next to
each other they wasn't even holding
hands that's an amazing point so like he
looked for a second launch she can [__]
whoever she wants I agree so so overall
are you here for the relationship I'm
here for it for both of them I think
it's like good like I said Taylor needs
a tall man is this a painful
conversation for you okay I feel like I
she's not my taste but I wish her well
and like you respect her I respect the
hustle yes okay well our next story is
about your queen okay so Brittany Jean
is causing waves always and yesterday
she posted really an alarming video
alarming at first it seemed like every
other video a little blurry vaseline on
the lens in the living room with the
stripper pole the low-rise show Arts the
sexy dance moves but this time the cap
sleeve top yes with the uh with the
elastic yeah yeah yeah but this time she
was holding two knives and I think that
really when I saw it I was like oh no
she has offered an explanation which I
do feel like makes it a little better
yeah what was it that they were fake
right no so she tells fans to lighten up
about the knives and she claimed that
she was copying Shakira yeah no no
that's I knew that was the reference I
didn't knew she was referencing a former
work of art which does make not even
former Shakira whipped out knives at the
VMAs I believe this year so that I
understood the reference immediately oh
that's so funny I did it oh I did and I
didn't even watch the VMAs and I did
so I her referencing something like
makes it a little less scary yeah but I
just don't think she's like at a place
in her life where she should be just
like messing around with knives I don't
know if anybody should really ever no no
no no no no safety is real uh I I cut
myself cutting cucumbers in the in the
in the kitchen
thank you
um
I I mean remember when Lindsay had that
knife out
doesn't he Lohan with the knife and she
was like holding it in a picture
in the salon through the knife yes oh my
God that's so Lindsay it's just it's a
little yeah and like whipping them
around and dancing with it it was quick
movement I know like nunchucks so but
part of me feels like I thought there
was a my friend sent me a comment on
Britney's thing that said they were fake
oh they were Halloween well they were
fake then that's different but they
didn't look fake is what I'm gonna say
she wrote I started playing with in the
kitchen with knives today you're right
she went on to clarify that she edited
the caption that they are not real
Halloween is soon do you think there was
someone from her team does she have a
team that's a good question I don't
think that she has a team but other
Twitter users Express concern one
writing that the knives were 100 real
because an audible clang yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's a good point too but you
know sometimes I have like
plastic that clings
yeah I feel like it's a different kind
but I respect you know you wanting to
protect your queen no it's just like
yeah the knives are Choice neither of
choice and I I felt uncomfortable I did
too and um it wouldn't be my thing I I
just don't think that as much as I love
her unhinchedness I don't think that
she's unhinged enough to dance that
frantically with knives yeah and I
honestly don't think that she's that
skilled enough to dance with knives and
not injure herself so maybe that does
conclude that they were in fact fake
perhaps I just you know she's no she's
not with Sam anymore so like who is in
the house to tell her like don't play
did she get a new assistant I don't know
I'm I'm not like a Britney Stan I
thought I read something where she was
in the car with her new assistant
interesting her assistance except for
Felicia if we remember the good old
Felicia days
she was a good assistant the assistants
passed 2006 debatable I feel like I
could see on one of those documentaries
about Brittany just as like a super fan
giving insight into like you like read
the legal documents like you just know a
lot about the legal documents I'm not I
I don't have the attention span to do
that my book's only 220 pages so a legal
document no I want to thank you for that
I love the short Books thank you I think
short books get to the point are vastly
underrated yeah I love that thank you so
we're wishing Brittany well as usual as
always oh I wanted to get your take on
something because last week we reported
you know she has to promote her book
coming up you know you're doing a lot of
podcasts
she's not really in the space to do that
so they're getting creative and I don't
know if you saw their re-releasing
Crossroads in theaters work do you love
that I didn't even see that
um you know I don't need to go to the
theaters to see it
and to be honest I think my favorite
part of that movie is Kim Cattrall at
the end of course like down when she
come when Britney travels all the way
and Cambridge I was like get the [__]
out of me get out of my home get away oh
way peasant I was actually just watching
you know when they would release vhs's
they would do like bonus speeches yeah
they had like a scene with Kim Cattrall
and Brittany and I guess I didn't
realize at the time but it was filmed
during like the peak of Sex in the City
this was just like and she was like
begging Brittany to come to the set you
would love the girls it's honestly an
amazing oh to Sex in the City yes that
would have been a great Cameo I know Sex
in the City did Sex in the City and Will
and Grace did the best cameos and
Brittany what did do a cameo on uh one
of the best cameos on Will and Grace
ever let me say you know what else has
great cameos because I'm re-watching it
right now the nanny oh yes and some of
the best Fashions the best fashion the
best Fashions you've ever had Elizabeth
Taylor on work it was it's like much
older so I feel like people don't like
consider it as like one of those binge
watching shows everybody watching it's
so good it's and like and like
franchisors everything hot
cancer survivor did not she
Queen although I did read
she Buddhism but we still we still claim
her we still claim her like as like uh
as a people you know yeah always yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right our next story
is a little Dancing with the Stars news
now overall describe your Dancing with
the Stars experience in one word oh uh
uh um grueling yes grueling okay because
essentially physically and emotionally
it really and you had the physical but
some people go on who aren't you know in
their Peak Physical Fitness yeah yeah
and I think it's such a tough transition
I think Jamie Lynn will have a hard time
well as soon as she gets past episode
one
popularity it isn't well it is a
popularity contest and like they will
they've got elements that they can play
with as far as like the scoring to keep
certain people around and listen to me
if there's a Britney night this entire
season she's staying on I don't care if
it's if it's the semi-final they're
keeping her ass on till Brittany Knight
and then she's getting the boot by the
way I didn't even think of that and
that's an amazing call but if there's a
Britney night she's staying until there
and if there's not a Britney night
though the the time that she does a
Britney Spears song she's going home
that's a beautiful like if that's how it
plays out you just told a beautiful
story thank you now are you a Bravo
girly
um here and there okay are you keeping
up with Kyle and Mauricio oh what are
they separated are they together we
don't know they're like is she on a
lesbian journey is she not they're being
really unclear I think they're just kind
of waiting for the season to Premiere
where they tell the story but their
their narrative thus far is like we've
had we're having a rough year but we're
not separated and we're not divorced and
we're not lesbian oh like but but
there's evidence of the uh contrary they
just have an open marriage and that's
the gag that's the gag maybe that's a
gag so Mauricio's on Dancing With the
Stars yes Mauricio is extremely good
looking I think I think they are a very
hot couple yes they both look very good
and it's making waves that Kyle was
there supporting him oh good for him and
his little package you know they do his
little packages before the show he like
just weirdly blurts out this like
scripted line about his wife he's like
yeah we're having a rough year like
nobody asked it was so weird
um but I think the housewives Community
was was really aggged by it because
there's so much uncertainty and I think
he is he pretty much is regarded as the
hottest house husband wow
who would you say is hotter I would say
Evan gold Schneider but I'm biased
because he's Jewish he's from Jersey and
actually his wife has been demoted to
Friend of so he's like oh not a friend
of he's really nice what's the New
Jersey like what's the New Jersey apple
or Peach what is it uh that's a great
question what the [__] do they have a
wrench
bottle of hairspray can you look it up
they hold diamonds in Beverly Hills
peaches in Atlanta New York they hold
apples apples yeah what the hell do they
hold what's Beverly Hills a diamond a
diamond yeah
oh my clothes oh my God that's so funny
I never realized
that is so b b list right there no it's
giving like second tier yeah very much
but it's real they're all friend of but
by the way that's so interesting because
I think in the uh like tiers of
Housewives Jersey is very high up there
it's consistently good since the very
beginning okay fair so it's I was always
like an Atlanta girl yeah and then
Beverly Hills I got into but I've fallen
off and like it's hard to keep up with
it's just for me it's like it's too much
like we're about to fight and what are
we fighting about and like it's just
like I see it coming and it doesn't feel
authentic like if y'all are like [__]
fight I want to see y'all Knuck and buck
it's formulaic at this point which is
why I think when Potomac came out it was
so refreshing because like they did it
differently and they didn't give a [__]
and they weren't like out here and now
it's like what about a Housewives that's
like you know like supportive like no
drama like let's just okay no okay
what's your favorite unscripted reality
show oh
that's that's hard does drag race count
it does it's more of a company that's a
competition like the voice I don't know
I'm not like are you not big into
reality no or I've I okay I did like the
first two seasons of selling Sunset I
mean it was some of the best so good
were you team Christine Quinn um I'm not
like okay remember in the second season
we're like at the finale they're like
girl you're being a mess like you keep
doing nasty things and she's like I
don't know what you're talking about it
just like was like at that point I was
like you're getting confronted like be a
cool human being but you know what guys
yes I am and I'm gonna try to do better
or like yes I am [__] you and I'm gonna
keep being a [__] I feel like you would
do great on reality I don't know I'm
very I would like defuse confrontation I
don't like confrontation people think
because like and maybe you too because
like we're very loud yeah people think
I'm like a fighter no no I'm so conflict
diverse I will run for the hills like I
will clench my butt I I hate I'll never
say anything I'll have a conversation
but I'm not gonna fight you I will I
won't be crazy especially physical like
no ma'am so it's nice to see that um
Kyla Mauricio are supporting one another
but do you think that the Dancing with
the Stars lifestyle is good for a
marriage in crisis I feel like you're
very busy
yeah it was uh I I would say no maybe
it's a good distraction maybe it's a
good time to be a part because we're
both focused in my book I read about how
Cheryl Burke was like uh about to she at
our season finale she was like this has
been a great distraction but I've got to
go figure out if I'm gonna be with my
husband yeah and and they're not and
they're not and she's with someone else
now right well I think he was dating the
girl TLC or 3lw no TLC TLC
yeah yeah that was like the craziest
Saga for the 90s kids yeah yeah I
enjoyed it and with the brothers and
they do a podcast with the brothers
that's the thing everything in pop
culture comes back to a podcast which is
why I love what I do today's episode is
also brought to you by Squarespace the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place and all on your
terms cause girl it's 2023 like if you
don't have a website for your business
whatever your business is you're
slacking you're behind and I know it can
be very intimidating like who knows how
to code a website I'm gonna have to pay
a million dollars to a company you don't
Squarespace is here for you whether
you're an amateur whether you're getting
started out whether you've been in
business for 10 years whether you need
an e-commerce website whatever your
needs are Squarespace will have it
covered for you they have so many
different features like if you wanna
sell custom merch you can do that on a
Squarespace website if you want to have
an online store like you work in
e-commerce but maybe you have a side
hustle you just have a business that's
e-commerce you can sell your products in
an online store and they have flexible
website templates so their templates
will like literally build the website
for you you just put in your information
and it looks so professional it'll look
so fancy like you paid someone so much
money but it's really just you in
Squarespace a team of two they also
allow you to do email campaigns they
have a great point of sale so if you
sell things in person like at trade
shows or farmers markets you can connect
a square reader to your Squarespace app
so you'll keep up with your orders your
inventory customer data it'll all be in
sick in sync with your online store
so if you want to get started on
Squarespace head to squarespace.com for
a free trial when you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com toast to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain that's squarespace.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by seed so it's got Mania you know
there's over four million posts on
Instagram tagged hashtag gut health I
feel like everybody is trying to get
their guts in order it's like an issue
everyone's having and that's where seed
comes in seed is everything they're ds01
daily symbiotic is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strain
that has been clinically and
scientifically studied for its benefits
it's free from 14 classes of allergens
so you don't have to worry about
anything it's sugar-free it's vegan it's
soy free it's Sesame free it's gluten
free it's peanut free it's dairy free
it's shellfish free it's corn free
here's how it works you take two
capsules once a day on an empty stomach
so that could be like the first thing in
the morning or two hours after your last
meal and what's so great about it and
why it's different from other prebiotics
and probiotics is that it's engineered
to survive your external and internal
environments like if you've taken a
probiotic and you feel like it doesn't
do any do anything that's because it's
actually not making its way down your
digestive tract but seeds capsule and
capsule via cap safeguards viability
through digestion for delivery of an
average hundred percent of your
probiotic starting to your colon the
outer capsule also serves as an elegant
barrier from oxygen moisture and heat
and there's no Refrigeration necessary
so whatever your reasons for wanting to
get your gut in check there's also so
many other benefits just getting your
gut health in a good place like your
skin like there's a million reasons so
the seed ds01 daily symbiotic is
fabulous and visit seed.com toast and
use code toast to redeem 30 off your
first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed
s-e-e-d.com slash toast and use code
toast
um our next story what are your thoughts
before I like keep saying the story I
just want like your take on the person
okay what if that's in the Kardashians
oh
um
like Iris Iris it's kind of like Taylor
like I respect the hustle not
necessarily for me I also like like I re
I respect how family oriented they are
yes I respect the hustle yes but I also
think that they've been really toxic for
like pop culture and the way that we
especially women view themselves like I
think it's y'all there's a lot of
surgeries going on there nothing wrong
with that if you want the surgeries go
for it I don't care but like don't act
like they aren't there no I will say
like I ride hard for the Kardashians
similar to Taylor but I feel like
there's a lot of really valid criticisms
of the Kardashians like anybody and the
difference is like when I think people
criticize Taylor like I think it's
invalid like I think it's dumb like with
the Kardashians like I I agree like
there's a lot of things about them that
I could you know agree with you on if
you were going to criticize yeah get
your coin but like get your coin
responsible yeah yeah
so Kourtney Kardashian had a baby shower
and it appears this is a baby number I
think it's her fourth but it's her first
with Travis soccer Courtney has four
kids yeah she had three with Scott three
Penelope Mason and rain oh and now she's
having one with Travis Barker from
Blink-182 okay so they had a a baby
shower and they were like posting a
bunch of content and I think they
spilled the beans on the baby's name
because it was a deleted Instagram story
where they were like all writing notes
to the baby and it said Dear baby Rocky
r-o-c-k-y
two one what are your thoughts it's I
think it's trying a little hard because
he's like a rocker yeah and just like
it's thematic what happened to Joshua
what happened to Matthew what what
happened to biblical names like
just just bring it back why do we have
to be so creative what is like do you
want to have kids
um like 95 no I like my time off I like
my money
um I still haven't unpacked all my
trauma so I'm like not trying to put
that on so we'll see what's like your
baby name you love oh I know this is
really weird and like and it all stems
from a movie but I've always I've always
loved the num the name Vincent from what
movie is that I think it's uh Ethan
Hawke in like Gattaca or something like
that interesting I know that's so Random
do you think Vince Vaughn is hot Vince
no you don't no no my mom does
so hot maybe like he's not attractive to
gays because I feel like a lot of women
think he's hot but I don't see like the
gays he was like he was in like Wedding
Crashers yeah yeah no no he's not
attracted oh my God I find him so cute
yeah yeah I know so who do you think is
like the hottest whoa straight straight
male celebrities a straight male
celebrity of all time or like current
current oof
um I'm just trying to gauge your type
wow that's I have a lot of varied types
maluma is really hot agreed but like
also a Bad Bunny but like in a different
way
um Chris Evans is hot dog
um the Hemsworth is hot Chris Hemsworth
is hot Liam Hemsworth Miley Cyrus's
ex-husband he's fine he's fine he's fine
I agree it's hot but like I'm not
gagging so who do you think is the
hottest gay male celebrity oh wow wow
wow because there's only one answer oh
it's Luke Evans
oh my God it might just be that I like
want to [__] Gaston oh he is he is very
hot and he's an amazing voice he has an
amazing voice and he's definitely like
um
I I could see him having a good time
he keeps it on the low but like I think
he does I think he likes to party I
think he's like definitely a [__] but I
think he keeps it on low I have nothing
to back that up it's just on intuition
no but he has been like criticized by
the community for not being like so
public and and out with his sexuality
and he's just said like I'm a private
person yeah what are your thoughts on
that that's fair I think that's okay
that's fair like what
um
could he do more sure we could all do
more could he do
do you think about ever like when you
get on the bike who's watching because I
feel like everyone has a Peloton
especially peltons are expensive so like
celebrities definitely have yeah yeah
are you ever thinking like maybe Barbra
Streisand's watching my Peloton do you
think dabs not not her specifically like
do you think no I I guess I'm not
thinking about it
um I'm just like trying to get get
through
um I'm not really worried about what
celebrity is he's taking my that's
somebody that's literally all I would do
yeah because it would be the only thing
to get me through I'd be like girl stop
sweating like get it together I'm always
wearing eyes watching here's my thing
and like I went to
um I went to the vice president's house
and I tried to ask all the staffers who
Joe Biden's favorite Peloton instructor
was just because I'm curious for a fact
that he Toms he has a bike I know he has
a bike wow because it was like there was
an article that was like is he gonna
take it to the White House because like
I don't even care if it's me I just want
to know I feel like it really could be
you maybe is there any like drama like
between the different writers I mean the
different instructors yeah everyone
tries to ask that and like honestly no I
wish I wish there was we're pretty like
all supportive of each other like yeah
we're all doing our own thing but like
we all like support each other the best
we can
um I think the most drama is like I get
really annoyed with the girls because
like we have two dressing two like
changing rooms in the green room and
there's like sometimes like eight of us
in there or like five or six and then
like I don't even go in there yeah it's
a lot like I wanna I just it's like
living with your sisters and I don't
have sisters and like trying to share
two bathrooms right so that's the most
tea I can give you is the Peloton HQ
studio in New York yeah it's on 31st and
10th that's so interesting yeah so you
go every day not every day like uh three
to five days a week it depends on the
week and this might be a damn question
yeah are the classes live or the
pre-recorded so majority of the classes
are live and then go on Demand right
um we have people in the classes like a
live studio audience I've seen that
Thursday Friday Saturday Sun like one on
Thursday one on Monday and then all day
Friday Saturday Sunday and if somebody
wanted to sign up for that how would
they do it you have to like go online
and find tickets I and I'm not I'm not
trying to compare myself but so many of
the girlys have just been like it's it's
easier to get Taylor Swift tickets than
to get a bike in my class I believe that
how many bikes there's only 40. so like
you know I'm not selling out MET life
but like you know it's hard it's hard to
get a ticket it counts and if they if
they could be on StubHub they might they
might they might I love that that's so
cool it's like a like a concert yeah a
little bit but you couldn't do it during
covid right no oh my god well with
people people in the thing people yeah
no absolutely not we didn't have people
back in the studio until like last
summer when you were I didn't know this
but when you were talking about you
getting covered during Dancing with the
Stars and you have to dance in your
house on Zoom yes was that one of the
lower points of your life I almost quit
no I know it was like week two I called
my boss and I was like listen I don't
know I don't know I don't know can I
just like quit right she's like no
you're not quitting and also Cheryl
Burke was like [__] you're not quitting
I was like okay we'll figure it out so I
had to set up my whole living room and
dance to Britney Spears in my living
room I'm sorry that was hysterical I
know it was I just wanted to get through
the night and the thing is like I was
like I did all this hard work and they
still gave me [__] scores you know what
you should have gotten tens tens tens
across the board just for that just
given the circumstance thank you give me
a little pity here that's so funny all
right our fifth Story before we dive
into some advice is Major news in the
world of Airbnb oh you can now spend the
night in Shrek's swamp oh I saw that
it's in Ireland it's in Scotland so the
mud Laden moss-covered murky watered
swamp is situated among the Rolling
Hills of Scotland where guests can stay
up late swap stories and eat like an
ogre because in the morning donkey's
making waffles so they have really
recreated here I'll show you a picture
but I I also need a man that looks like
human Shrek
to to greet me with breakfast I agree
because human Shrek was hot you think
yeah you tap that I tap it what about
donkey smash or pass
I am an ass man so smash good answer did
we use that one okay we did okay that
wasn't a ride so oh that's funny I love
I think Airbnb is getting so creative
you know you could stay in Gwyneth
Paltrow's uh guest Cottage
that's rich how much is it I mean and is
she there it was like a sweepstakes so
only one person's gonna do it and yes
should you attempt dinner with her and
her husband oh that uh sounds I would be
so hungry after that meal we would be
Uber eating Postmates yeah yeah yeah
yeah all the way just yeah double up on
that ozone big girl okay
it's a fabulous idea I think you know
it's hard in this day and age every
Media company so there you can't even
get an Airbnb in New York anymore so but
you can be at Shrek's house is
um
who is universal not coming for these
people I'm sure it's a partnership
between whoever owns the Shrek and
universities Pixar no no no no it's
Universal because they have a Shrek ride
at Universal Studios are you a Disney
adult okay I have a Mickey Mouse tattoo
but I do not identify I do not identify
as a Disney adult I just love Mickey
okay you could read me let's get one
thing straight you came for the swifties
when you're a full-blown Disney adult
that is Rich it is it is how many times
a year you go to Disney okay okay okay
here's the thing I went twice this year
twice this year I know
I hadn't been since 2018. okay and me
and my friends were like let's go and my
friend Corey is definitely a dizzy adult
and he planned the whole trip so I was
like work beautiful amazing Disney World
is that Orlando yeah Orlando with all
the parks yeah so we went we had a great
time fantastic
two months later Disney calls me and
asks me to do an event there and they
were like we will fly you out we'll give
you a hotel and we'll give you and your
friends
access to the park I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say no to them you're a
businessman I'm not gonna say no to that
I agree so I said yes to it so that is
why I've been twice second time doesn't
count thank you so much okay so the
tattoo is a little misleading I know
what which is was your first tattoo I'm
so interested this one right here my
tattoos I have this one right here it's
a heart on the top of my hand and I have
it with my best friend so when we shake
hands it's right there I also this is
the first one I got and I got it drunk
at a party because I worked for this I
freelanced for this uh experiential
marketing company okay and they had a
tattoo artist at their holiday come at
their holidays very experiential yep and
so my friend was like you're drunk
enough I always he'd always been a
pressure me to get a tattoo and so we
got a tattoo so how many did you have
because four and then I'm done before
I'm done all on one arm all in one arm
keep it keep keep it right here and I I
honestly don't want to get any more
because there have been so many photo
shoots that I've done that they have to
cover them up because this artist they
can never get a hold of her to like
copyright to like sign off on it right
and I'm just like enough no in the
Disney one is a big issue yeah
interesting interesting all right well
thank you for doing the stories because
we love Hot Topics great and we have
three submissions so we do a weekly
segment it's called deer toaster so if
you guys ever want to submit to you you
know get some advice from two unhinged
girlies feel free to head to the
toastpodcast.com submission is totally
Anonymous and we picked some raunchy
ones for you yeah
but I figured yes oh congratulations for
like 100 years oh wonderful beautiful
ring thank you so much I just got it
resized because it was that big it
didn't fit anymore oh how what and that
that was a good problem to have I can't
lie like I went to pick it up at the
Jeweler yesterday and like I I'm so
skinny like I just couldn't did you love
did you love going to the jeweler like
guys I've lost a lot of weight and I
really need to read resize this rig I
did but like the size of my ring before
was like actually embarrassing oh okay
let me tell you my sister her engagement
ring is a size three and a half okay
mine was a seven and a half oh my God I
just had these like big sausage fingers
and so yes it was a win but I'm glad to
have those fingers every penny he's been
worth every penny okay ready hey guys I
found you guys on Tick Tock I need
advice in a bad way
are you obsessed with Tick Tock I was
stalking yourself and that's kind of
where I've found you guys before too I
gotta love it okay so I was going
through my boyfriend's phone and it came
across
we're going through your man's phone
true
you have no try like you don't trust I'm
gonna tell you just break up now yeah
you don't you don't trust this man it
gets worse the the relationship is in
turmoil but keep going and it's so true
Jackie always says like if you're gonna
go snooping you're gonna find something
you don't want to see so like and it's
gonna it's gonna
re-solidify whatever thoughts or
insecurities that you're gonna have so
no matter what you see you're gonna see
it through the lens that you want to see
it through but go keep going so I was
going through my boyfriend's phone and
it came across a picture I took of one
of my friends in her bathing suit that
was on my camera roll it was never on a
social media platform the photo even
said in the top Corner live because she
had taken the live photo I asked him
about it and he claimed he screenshotted
it off of Instagram which I debunked
immediately this was never posted he
gave no further explanation for himself
and denied that he saved it for my
camera roll which was the only place
that that picture was I'm just not sure
how to move forward with this
information
well he obviously has access to your
phone right you two are both zooming
through each other's phones you're both
zooming through each other's phones I do
want to offer one potential like I don't
think that this is what happened but I
could see I'd love to airdrop I'm always
airdropping things and you know
sometimes when you select a bunch of
photos so you also pick like a random
one yeah yeah so have you recently
airdropped your boyfriend something it's
probably not probably not and also he
said he but he also said he clicked it
from Instagram so like yeah you're right
you're right he's he already like told
on himself it's clear that you guys have
like major trust issues you guys have
major trust issues he needed some um
content to jack off to unfortunately
it's of your best friend or your friend
in a bikini
um uh I I think you guys have trust
issues you might want to just like go
ahead and uh uh call it quits on this
one I'm sorry I I kind of agree this
first of all it's just weird because now
you can never hang out with his friend
and your boyfriend two he's scrolling
through your phone you're scrolling
through his phone this just sounds like
red flag alert everywhere yeah I just
don't think this is like a great
relationship yeah or yeah how do you say
how do you how would you like Salvage
this that's
I think
you're beyond a point where like
communication because you you confront
him good on you like you saw something
about him and you confront him and he
just lied so you're making no progress
yeah he's gaslighting you like you
literally saw the photo it's Live Like
Us Tech girlies like we know we work in
I.T like we know you can't screenshot
alive right here thank you we know I
hate when people like like I'm speaking
facts and you're not yeah yeah it's
frustrating I agree with Cody I don't
think that this is like right for you
nope all right ready for our next one
yes
and the first one wasn't no this one's
like actually okay it's not weird it's
um I actually don't know how to help
this girl oh okay I'm a fairly new
listener but I have a dilemma and I
think that you can help my fiance and I
have been together for almost four years
we have a wonderful relationship and a
great sex life okay a few months ago I
tried calling him daddy in bed and he
really liked it yes it didn't do much
for me but I didn't dislike it and he
did like it so I started using it every
now and then okay the issue is when he
started calling himself Daddy all the
time I find it so cringy and icky I
don't want to embarrass him by telling
him it's cringy so I just do I stop
using it and hope that he does and it
fades or do I find a nice way to tell
him to stop much love and thank you for
your input
I feel like you're equipped to answer
this oh I I love that this I loved where
the story was going I know like and then
like every other straight man they
ruined it too far they took it too far I
know like you can't really call yourself
Daddy no no no no like in the third
person I'm sure it's in that they're
like daddy likes that I'm also like do
that for Daddy yeah oh it's over
breakfast she's saying not even in sex
anymore oh just a good man Daddy needs
to do his laundry like stop oh stop okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait you might have
to lie a little bit here okay here's my
here's my solve okay
hey babe I it really [__] turns me on
when you like when I call you Daddy in
bed
but like it I really want it to be in
the bedroom and special so can you save
it and can I because you're so hot and
like you have all the power can I be the
one that only calls you Daddy I love
that
[Music]
yeah I'm doing it for you it's like I
want you to feel special and I want to
be kind of like submissive and be the
one that does it right and also like if
you just come out and tell him like he
will be embarrassed and like yeah yeah
it does it is something that started in
the bedroom and you just don't want to
cause anything yeah so like just say
like you really want to keep it in the
bedroom like it's my thing like it only
works when I do it yeah yeah yeah
without embarrassing it I actually
pretty good advice I actually think
that's excellent advice I will add
nothing further okay great our third and
final one
my boyfriend just broke up with me okay
pre-breakup he gave me a 10 carat
diamond tennis necklace from The Ring
concierge as a commitment to me for
Valentine's Day
use code toast
it feels weird to keep it now that he
has broken up with me and he's broken
that commitment but it's also 10 carats
do I keep it do I sell it give it to my
mom give it back to him love you both so
much definitely don't give it back to
him definitely if he has a ring
concierge he has money he has money he's
not worried about this 10K bracelet
here's the thing like in the state of
New York like an engagement ring or any
sort of like jewelry it's considered a
gift you don't have to give it back
wonderful the law is on your side and he
has money isn't that part of the female
experience like when you're 80 you have
this box of things you're like oh my
first first boyfriend gave me this oh
this was my first engagement like you
collect mementos of your love life and
this is just one of them keep it if you
fall upon Hard Times sell that stuff
it's not 10 carrots honestly I say sell
it oh because here's the thing I read an
article how like you know Millennials
gen Z like they're moving away from real
diamonds no offense to your ring over
there they're moving they're moving into
like synthetics that like really look
well so I think the value of diamonds is
gonna drop this is coming from the
business side of me so sell it now cash
out and like invest it in something else
okay
I could one make the argument that
because everyone's moving away from
Earth mine diamonds they're going to
become more aware and therefore more
valuable I think that's you know it's
possible hope you'll be just being
hopeful but that's fine what did I what
I've been doing I think I don't think
we're gonna run out of diamonds that's
fair I don't think we're gonna run out
of diamonds I think that the market will
be there and like I don't think you need
to like what Are You Gonna Keep On like
when you get to your new man like are
you gonna wear this necklace I just want
to say like I think you should keep it
okay we're we're in a disagreement I
think both offer neither scenario is bad
or good you sell it you get money sell
sell sell baby you're investing in
yourself yes and you keep it you always
have diamonds on you like you know you
never know when you have to flip from
The Ring concierge
Cody you give amazing advice thank you
so much you have amazing hot takes I'm
so happy to have met you you are welcome
back anytime thank you you really
smashed it thank you pun intended
exactly now I cannot recommend this book
enough I'm literally so excited to go
home and finish it I'm almost done XOXO
Cody anywhere you get books yes you can
follow Cody on all the social media
platforms at Cody Rigsby uh I think Tick
Tock is like a a space or a dash because
like someone had my name that's
disgusting I know [__] them and I tried
to get them banned but it didn't work
it's just it's okay okay I'm the you
know the one with the check mark no
you're the one yeah it doesn't you're a
celebrity thank you so much bring it
back
um so make sure to follow them
everywhere catch him on Peloton and
enjoy the book Thank you so much for
being here thanks for having me and
thank you guys so much for listening to
the chose the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so at Spotify
iTunes sister public radio I already
castbox all the places five star review
about a beautiful standing in wickedly
talented we are have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow bye
foreign